You know what I didn’t like about Django
Unchained?
What?
The 4 or 500 uses of the n-word?
No.
Wait a minute.
Are we gonna hold this movie about the slave
era to our modern political correctness standards?
What were the white people in the movie supposed
to call black people?
Disappointments?
Are we gonna use something innocuous so that
we don’t get any historical accuracy in our
ears.
Well there’s a difference between historical
accuracy and overkill man.
They used that word, like, three times a sentence
in that movie,
That’s not an exaggeration at all.
You wanna talk about historical accuracy,
let’s talk about Jackie Brown, let’s talk
about Pulp Fiction.
Okay, let’s talk about ‘em.
Those movies are both set in the 90’s and
shot in the 90’s, the single most PC era
that’s ever existed, and the n-word’s all
over both of those movies.
I mean, in Pulp Fiction Tarantino says the
word like it’s a stutter.
And he says it to Samuel L. Jackson’s face.
That guy’s gotta have titanium balls.
I think people are just too sensitive about
words these days.
People are too sensitive about some words
these days… but the n-word, they’re not
being too sensitive.
That word is f*ckin’ toxic, man.
There’s only one word more controversial
than that.
Which is?
(CENSORED)
Dude I—you do know this is all on camera
right.
Like, I cannot believe you just said that.
If Tarantino can say the n-word to Samuel
L. Jackson, then why can’t I say the naughty
words and flaunt it?
That word isn’t naughty, dude, that word
is apocalyptic.
Besides, I’m sure that Sam Jackson had a
conversation with--
Yeah, “Sam” Jackson, like he’s you’re
buddy.
Okay, Samuel L. Motherf*cking Jackson.
The point is, do you think he would have done
the movie if he was offended?
He certainly wasn’t offended by the paycheck.
Dude, everybody worked for scale on that movie.
It was made for 8 million dollars and half
of that probably went to the gimp.
Oh, a gimp doesn’t cost anything.
Come on.
I can have a gimp here by 5 PM, with accessories.
The point is, about Django Unchained I didn’t
like the scene where they were taking Django
to the mine.
What was wrong with that?
Well, everything.
It feels tacked on, Tarantino indulges his
acting bug again playing an Australian slave
driver.
The scene’s only there, so it can pay off
the horrible things Django did.
Django was the hero...
Was he?
Was he really?
Let's remember he’s coming back to save his
wife.
That's a noble thing...
Yeah, it’s noble.
But think about what he has to do to save
his wife.
He transforms into this method actor, becoming
a black bounty hunter so vile he makes Uncle
Tom look like Snow White.
Yeah, he had to convince Leonardo DiCaprio.
Right, but then even after he had convinced
DiCaprio and everybody else, he still lets
that other black guy get lynched, without
stopping it, even though Christoph Waltz is
there and offers to pay good money to save
the guy.
And the only way that pays off is if there's
something that happens in the story later
on where he can then be vouched for by slaves
who can say, you know, he’s not with us,
or he’s not one of us.
The scene where he's being led to the mines...
Yes.
You just allowed all this suffering and let
a man die a horrible death just in the event
you were being led away into a remote mine…
just in the event other slaves were with you
that could vouch for your story… and just
in the event the white people believe your
story and let you go… then maybe it would
pay off and you could go see your wife again.
I say in the end, Django was the thing he
was pretending to be.
I say I’d like to see you say that to a group
of black people.
I don’t really know any black people.
That’s racist.
You don’t really know any black people either.
Yeah, but I don't go around telling everybody
about it.